Je ne suis pas tout à fait certaine d'avoir vraiment envie de voir
une caisse claire à neuf heures du matin.
Mais c'est quand même génial de voir ce théâtre aussi plein
et je tiens vraiment à remercier Herbie Hancock
et ses collègues pour leur superbe présentation.
Ce qui est intéressant
est évidemment l'association du touché brut de la main sur l'instrument
et de la technologie, et bien entendu ce qu'il a dit à propos d'écouter les jeunes.
Bien sûr, écouter est mon travail,
et mon but est véritablement d'enseigner au monde à écouter.
C'est mon seul vrai but dans la vie.
Et cela semble fort simple, mais c'est en fait un énorme boulot.
Parce que, lorsqu'on regarde une partition -- par exemple,
si j'ouvre mon petit sac de moto -- il y a, je l'espère,
une partition remplie de petits points noirs sur la page.
On l'ouvre, et je lis la musique.
Donc, techniquement, je suis à même de lire ceci.
Je suivrai les instructions, les marques de tempo, la dynamique.
Je ferai exactement ce qu'on me dit.
Et ainsi donc, le temps étant compté,
Si je vous joue littéralement juste les 2 premières lignes. C'est très simple.
Ce morceau n'est pas très difficile.
Mais ici, on me dit que ce morceau est très rapide.
On me dit où jouer sur le tambour.
On me dit quelle partie de la baguette utiliser.
Et on m'indique la dynamique.
Et on me dit aussi que la caisse est sans timbre.
Avec timbre, sans timbre.
Ainsi donc, si je traduis cette partition, voilà l'idée.
Et ainsi de suite. Ma carrière durera probablement 5 ans environ.
Néanmoins, en tant que musicienne, je me dois de faire tout ce qui n'est pas dans la musique.
Tout ce que l'on n'a pas le temps d'apprendre d'un professeur,
ou même de discuter avec un professeur.
Mais ce sont les choses que l'on remarque lorsque l'on n'est pas en présence de son instrument
qui deviennent en fait intéressantes, et que l'on veut explorer
via la minuscule surface d'un tambour.
Nous avons ici fait l'expérience de la traduction. Maintenant, faisons l'expérience de l'interprétation.
Ma carrière durera maintenant un peu plus longtemps !
D'une certaine façon, c'est la même chose que si je vous regarde et que je vois
une jolie jeune femme pétillante portant un haut rose.
Je vous vois serrer un ours en peluche, et cetera et cetera.
Alors je me fais une idée générale de ce que vous êtes, ce que vous pourriez aimer
quelle pourrait être votre profession, et cetera et cetera.
Pourtant, il s'agit juste de la première impression que nous avons tous
lorsque nous regardons. Et nous essayons d'interpréter,
mais ceci est en fait incroyablement superficiel.
De la même manière, je regarde la musique, je m'en fais une idée de base
je me demande quelles sont les difficultés techniques ou ce que je veux faire.
Seulement le sentiment initial.
Cependant ce n'est tout simplement pas assez.
Et je pense à ce qu'a dit Herbie " Écoute s'il te plaît, écoute."
Dans un premier temps, nous devons nous écouter nous-mêmes.
Si je joue, par exemple en tenant la baguette -- de manière à ne pas la laisser aller --
on ressent beaucoup de choc le long du bras.
Et croyez le ou non, on se sent vraiment très
séparé de l'instrument et de la baguette,
même si, en fait, je tiens la baguette très fermement.
En la tenant fermement, je me sens étrangement plus détachée.
Si je lâche prise et que je permets à ma main, mon bras de devenir un dispositif de support
j'ai soudainement plus de dynamique en fournissant moins d'effort. Beaucoup plus.
Et enfin, je sens que je ne fais plus qu'un avec la baguette et le tambour.
Et j'en fais beaucoup, beaucoup moins.
Alors, de la même manière que j'ai besoin de temps avec cet instrument,
j'ai besoin de temps avec les gens afin de les interpréter.
Pas seulement les traduire, mais les interpréter.
Si je joue par exemple quelques mesures d'un morceau de musique
pour lequel je me vis comme une technicienne
c'est-à-dire quelqu'un qui est fondamentalement une percussionniste...
et ainsi de suite. Si je me vis comme une musicienne...
et ainsi de suite. Il y a là une petite différence à laquelle il est intéressant -- (Applaudissements)
-- de réfléchir.
Et je me souviens, lorsque j'avais 12 ans,
et que j'ai commencé à jouer des timbales et des percussions, mon professeur m'a dit,
"Eh bien, comment allons-nous faire ? Tu sais, la musique est une question d'écoute."
"Oui, je suis d'accord. Alors quel est le problème ?"
Et il m'a dit "Alors, comment vas-tu entendre ceci ? Comment vas-tu entendre cela ?"
Et j'ai dit "Eh bien, comment l'entendez-vous ?"
Il m'a dit, "Je crois que je l'entends par là."
Et j'ai dit, "Eh bien, je crois que moi aussi -- mais je l'entends également par mes mains,
par mes bras, mes pommettes, mon cuir chevelu, mon ventre, ma poitrine, mes jambes..."
Et ainsi, nous commencions absolument toutes les leçons par l'accordage de percussions --
en particulier, les timbales --
à un faible intervalle donné, une différence...
de cet ordre. Puis graduellement... et graduellement...
Et c'est stupéfiant que lorsque l'on ouvre son corps,
et qu'on ouvre sa main pour laisser la vibration traverser,
en fait la minuscule différence..
peut être ressentie avec le plus petit bout du doigt, ici.
Et ainsi, ce que nous faisions est que je posais mes mains sur le mur
de la salle de musique, et ensemble nous écoutions les sons des instruments,
et essayions vraiment de nous connecter avec ces sons
beaucoup, beaucoup plus largement qu'en dépendant simplement de l'oreille.
Parce que bien entendu, l'oreille est sujette à toute sortes de choses.
La pièce dans laquelle nous nous trouvons, l'amplification, la qualité de l'instrument,
le type de baguettes, et cetera, et cetera.
Elles sont toutes différentes.
Même poids, mais couleurs sonores différentes.
Et c'est fondamentalement ce que nous sommes. Nous sommes juste des êtres humains,
mais nous avons tous nos propres petites couleurs sonores, ainsi,
qui constituent ces personnalités extraordinaires
et ces caractères, et ces intérêts, et ces choses.
Et en grandissant, j'ai passé des auditions pour la Royal Academy of Music à Londres,
et il m'ont dit, "Eh bien non, nous ne vous acceptons pas, parce que nous n'avons pas la moindre idée
de l'avenir d'une 'musicienne sourde'."
Et je ne pouvais vraiment pas accepter ça.
Et par conséquent, je leur ai dit, "Eh bien, si vous refusez --
si vous me refusez pour ces raisons,
contrairement à l'aptitude à accomplir et comprendre et aimer
l'art de créer du son --
alors, nous devons vraiment nous interroger au sujet de ceux que vous acceptez."
Conséquemment -- après avoir franchi un petit obstacle, en devant être auditionnée deux fois --
ils m'ont acceptée. Et ce n'est pas tout --
ce qui venait d'arriver a changé complètement le rôle
des institutions musicales partout au Royaume Uni.
En aucun cas, ils ne pouvaient plus refuser quelque candidature que ce soit sur la base que
quelqu'un ait ou non des bras, des jambes --
ils étaient peut-être capable de jouer d'un instrument à vent s'il était fixé sur un pied.
Sous aucun prétexte ils ne pouvaient refuser une inscription.
Et chaque inscription devait être écoutée, éprouvée et alors
sur la base de l'aptitude musicale -- alors la personne était acceptée ou non.
Et par conséquent, cela signifia qu'un groupe d'étudiants
extrêmement intéressants arrivèrent à leur tour dans diverses institutions musicales.
Et je dois dire, nombre d'entre eux sont maintenant
dans les orchestres professionnels à travers le monde.
Ce qui est également intéressant à ce sujet, toutefois --
(Applaudissements) --
est très simplement que non seulement ces personnes sont connectées au son --
ce qui est le cas de tout le monde, et aussi nous savons fort bien que la musique est notre médecine quotidienne.
Je dis musique, mais en fait je veux dire son.
Parce que parmi les choses extraordinaires que j'ai vécues
en tant que musicienne, quand par exemple vous avez un garçon de 15 ans
qui fait face à des difficultés incroyables,
qui n'est peut-être pas en en mesure de contrôler ses mouvements,
qui est peut-être sourd, qui est peut-être aveugle, et cetera, et cetera.
Soudain, si ce jeune garçon s'assied tout près de cet instrument,
et peut-être même s'allonge sous le marimba,
et que l'on joue quelque chose de très proche de l'orgue, presque --
je n'ai peut-être pas tout à fait les bonnes baguettes --
mais quelque chose de cet ordre. Je change.
Quelque chose de si incroyablement simple --
mais il ressentira quelque chose que je ne ressentirai pas,
parce que je suis en haut du son.
Le son m'arrive par là.
Quant à lui, le son lui arrivera par les résonateurs.
S'il n'y avait pas de résonateur là, ça donnerait --
ainsi il aura une ampleur de son que ceux d'entre vous aux premiers rangs
ne pourront ressentir; ceux d'entre vous dans les derniers rangs ne pourront pas le ressentir non plus.
Absolument chacun d'entre nous, en fonction de l'endroit où il est assis,
ressentira ce son de manière très très différente.
Et bien sûr, étant la créatrice du son,
et cela commence par l'idée de quel type de son je veux produire --
par exemple, ce son.
Entendez-vous quelque chose ?
Exactement. Parce que je ne le touche même pas.
Mais pourtant, nous avons la sensation qu'il se passe quelque chose.
De la même manière que lorsque je vois un arbre bouger,
j'imagine alors cet arbre faire un bruit de froissement.
Vous voyez ce que je veux dire ?
Quel que soit ce que l'oeil voit, il se produit toujours un son.
Il y a toujours, toujours cet énorme --
ce kaléidoscope de choses dans lesquelles puiser.
Toutes mes représentations sont basées entièrement sur ce que je ressens,
et non sur l'apprentissage d'un morceau de musique, en plaquant dessus l'interprétation d'un autre,
en achetant tous les CDs possibles de ce morceau en particulier et ainsi de suite.
Parce que cela ne me donne pas assez de quelque chose qui est si brut et si primordial,
et quelque chose dont je peux pleinement ressentir le parcours.
Alors il se peut que, dans certaines salles, cette dynamique fonctionne bien.
Il se peut que dans d'autres salles, ils ne le ressentiront tout simplement pas
du tout et par conséquent, mon niveau de jeu doux,
léger doive être --
voyez-vous ce que je veux dire ? Ainsi, du fait de cette explosion de l'accès au son,
en particulier dans la communauté des sourds,
cela n'a pas affecté que la manière dont les institutions musicales,
et les écoles pour sourds examinent le son. Et pas seulement comme une forme de thérapie --
même si bien sûr, en créant du son,
c'est certainement le cas également.
Mais cela implique que les acousticiens ont réellement dû réfléchir aux types de salles
qu'ils ont mis au point. Il y a si peu de salles en ce monde
qui ont réellement une très bonne acoustique,
oserai-je dire. Mais ce que je veux dire est "où l'on peut faire absolument tout ce que l'on imagine".
Du plus petit, plus léger son à quelque chose de si vaste,
si énorme, si incroyable ! Il y a toujours quelque chose --
il se peut que ça sonne bien là, mais pas si bien là.
Peut-être superbe là, mais horrible là.
Peut-être horrible par là-bas, mais pas si mal là, et cetera et cetera.
Donc c'est incroyable de trouver une salle
-- dans laquelle on peut jouer exactement ce que l'on imagine,
sans que cela soit cosmétiquement amélioré.
Et c'est pourquoi des acousticiens sont en fait en conversation avec
des malentendants, et qui sont créateurs sonores.
Et c'est très intéressant.
Je ne suis pas en mesure de vous donner des détails sur ce qui se produit réellement
avec ces salles, mais c'est juste le fait qu'ils aillent vers un groupe de gens
dont on a dit durant tant d'années,
"Comment peuvent-ils ressentir la musique? Voyez, ils sont sourds."
Nous faisons juste -- comme ça, et nous imaginons que c'est ça la surdité.
Ou nous faisons comme ça, et nous imaginons que c'est ça la cécité.
Lorsque nous voyons des gens dans un fauteuil roulant, nous présumons qu'il ne peuvent pas marcher.
Peut-être qu'ils peuvent marcher trois, quatre, cinq pas. Cela, pour eux, signifie qu'ils peuvent marcher.
D'ici un an, cela pourrait être deux pas de plus.
D'ici une année de plus, trois pas de plus.
Ce sont des questions d'une importance immense.
Alors lorsque nous nous écoutons les uns les autres,
Il est incroyablement important pour nous de vraiment tester notre faculté d'écoute.
D'utiliser nos corps comme des chambres de résonance. De cesser le jugement.
En ce qui me concerne, en tant que musicienne qui a affaire à 99 pourcent de musique nouvelle,
il m'est très facile de dire "Oh oui, j'aime ce morceau.
Oh non, je n'aime pas ce morceau." Et ainsi de suite.
Et je découvre que je dois réellement donner à ces morceaux de musique du temps.
Peut-être que le courant ne passe pas entre moi-même et ce morceau de musique en particulier.
Mais ça ne m'accorde pas le droit de dire que c'est un mauvais morceau.
Et vous savez, l'une des choses merveilleuses lorsque l'on est musicien,
est que c'est si incroyablement fluide.
Donc il n'y a pas de règles, pas de vrai, pas de faux, de comme ceci ou de comme cela.
Si je vous demandais de frapper dans vos mains -- Peut-être que je peux le faire.
Si je dis juste "frappez dans vos mains." Et créez le son du tonnerre.
Je pars du principe que nous connaissons tous le tonnerre.
Cela dit, je ne parle pas simplement du son,
je parle d'écouter vraiment ce tonnerre qui est en vous.
Et essayez svp de créer cela en frappant des mains. Essayez. Juste -- essayez svp.
(Applaudissements)
Très bien ! La neige. La neige. Avez-vous déjà entendu la neige ?
Public : non.
Evelyn Glennie: Eh bien alors, cessez de frapper dans vos mains. (Rires) Essayez encore.
Essayez encore. La neige.
Voyez, vous être réveillés.
La pluie. Pas mal. Pas mal.
Vous savez, la chose intéressante ici, pourtant, est que j'ai posé à un groupe d'enfants
il n'y a pas si longtemps exactement la même question.
Maintenant -- superbe imagination, merci beaucoup.
Cependant, aucun d'entre vous ne s'est levé de son fauteuil pour penser,
"Bien ! Comment puis-je frapper ? OK, peut-être...
-- peut-être puis-je utiliser mes bijoux pour créer plus de sons.
Peut-être puis-je utiliser d'autres parties de mon corps pour créer plus de sons."
Pas un seul d'entre vous n'a pensé à frapper d'une manière légèrement différente
autrement qu'assis dans vos sièges et en utilisant deux mains.
De la même manière que lorsque nous écoutons de la musique,
nous présumons qu'elle nous est versée entièrement par là.
C'est ainsi que nous ressentons la musique. Bien sûr ça n'est pas le cas.
Nous ressentons le tonnerre -- tonnerre, tonnerre. Pensez pensez pensez.
Écoutez écoutez écoutez. Maintenant -- que pouvons-nous faire avec le tonnerre ?
Je me souviens de mon professeur. Lorsque j'ai débuté, à ma toute première leçon,
j'étais complètement préparée avec les baguettes, prête.
Et au lieu de me dire, "OK Evelyn, s'il te plaît. Pieds légèrement écartés,
bras à un angle de plus ou moins 90 degrés, baguettes plus ou moins en V,
garde telle distance ici, et cetera.
Tiens toi droite, et cetera et cetera et cetera."
Où j'aurais probablement fini absolument rigide, figée,
et incapable de frapper le tambour,
parce que j'aurais pensé à tant d'autres choses, il m'a dit,
"Evelyn, emporte ce tambour 7 jours et on se verra la semaine prochaine".
Ciel ! Qu'allais-je faire ? Je n'avais plus besoin des baguettes,
je n'étais pas autorisée à les avoir.
J'ai dû observer ce tambour spécifique,
voir comment il était fabriqué, ce que faisaient ces petites vis, ce que faisait le timbre.
Le retourner, expérimenter avec la caisse, expérimenter avec la membrane.
expérimenter avec mon corps, expérimenter avec des bijoux,
expérimenter avec toutes sortes de choses.
Et bien sûr, je suis revenue avec toutes sortes de bleus et de choses comme ça --
mais néanmoins, ce fut une expérience tellement incroyable,
parce qu'alors, où diable allez-vous ressentir cela dans une partition ?
Où diable allez-vous ressentir cela dans un manuel ?
Alors nous n'avons jamais, jamais eu affaire à des manuels.
Par exemple, une des choses que nous apprenons
quand nous avons affaire à un percussionniste, par opposition avec un musicien,
est le simple roulé de base
Comme ceci. Et puis nous allons un peu plus vite et un peu plus vite.
Et ainsi de suite. Que nécessite ce morceau ?
Des roulés. Alors pourquoi ne le ferais-je pas en même temps que j'apprends un morceau de musique ?
Et c'est exactement ce qu'il fit.
Et, de façon intéressante, en grandissant, lorsque je suis devenue étudiante à plein temps
d'une soi-disant "institution musicale", tout cela s'est volatilisé.
Nous devions étudier avec des manuels.
Et constamment, la question, eh bien, pourquoi ? Pourquoi ? Avec quoi est-ce lié ?
Je dois apprendre à jouer un morceau. "Oh, ça va améliorer ton contrôle !"
Comment ? Pourquoi dois-je faire cela ? J'ai besoin de le relier avec un morceau.
Vous savez, je dois dire quelque chose.
Pourquoi est-ce que je m'exerce à faire des moulins ?
Est-ce littéralement pour le contrôle, le contrôle main-baguette ? Pourquoi est-ce que je fais ça ?
J'ai besoin d'avoir la raison,
et la raison doit être de communiquer quelque chose par la musique.
Et en communiquant quelque chose par la musique, qui est fondamentalement du son,
Il est possible d'enseigner toutes sortes de choses à toutes sortes de gens.
Mais je refuse de porter la responsabilité de votre bagage émotionnel.
C'est à vous de le faire, lorsque vous entrez dans une salle.
Parce que cela détermine alors ce que nous écoutons et comment nous écoutons certaines choses.
Je peux me sentir triste, ou joyeuse, ou euphorique, ou fâchée lorsque je joue
certains morceaux, mais je ne souhaite pas nécessairement
que vous ressentiez exactement la même chose.
Alors s'il vous plaît, la prochaine fois que vous irez à un concert,
laissez simplement votre corps s'ouvrir, laissez votre corps être cette caisse de résonance.
Soyez conscient que vous n'éprouverez pas la même chose que l'interprète.
L'interprète est à la pire place possible vis-à-vis du son réel,
ils entendent le contact de la baguette sur le tambour,
ou du maillet sur le morceau de bois, ou de l'archet sur la corde, et cetera.
Ou le souffle qui crée le son dans les instruments à vent ou les cuivres
Ils éprouvent là ce caractère primitif.
Mais ils éprouvent pourtant quelque chose de si incroyablement pur,
qui se situe avant que le son ne se produise.
Prêtez attention à l'existence du son avant que la frappe,
ou le souffle initial ne se produisent. Ressentez le trajet intégral de ce son,
tout comme j'aurais voulu ressentir le trajet intégral
de cette conférence, plutôt que d'arriver seulement hier soir.
J'espère que nous pourrons partager une chose ou deux au fil de la journée.
Mais merci beaucoup de m'avoir reçue !
(Applaudissements)